[Music]
fists items let's begin a few of you did
keep your hand up all the way through
does any want to give me this brief as
they can what his absolute value about
what is it okay so when you think about
integers they can be positive and
negative okay absolute value is closely
connected to taking away the negative
like things could only be positive okay
that's a good start thinking of it
anything else okay so this absolute
value idea is very closely connected to
distance which I'm going to work into my
definition it's something that I've
heard so far from all views it's not
numbers right I can take the absolute
value of this number or that number or I
can find the distance between this
number or that number as extension one
students we're going to expand this and
figure out the absolute values not just
a numbers better whole functions
remember I showed you this just now that
this which is a very good example but
we're going to apply absolute values not
just to numbers but to entire algebraic
objects okay so I'm going
let me count one two three definitions
for what an absolute value is
definitions and the first thing is know
is what notes in value is in terms of
notation is these two long vertical
Wyant the actual technical major the
signal is a pipe but I'm just going to
call them absolute value signs okay so
when you see them around that to be
quite long because you don't want to uh
if you've got something like the
absolute value of negative one you don't
want it to look like one take away 11
okay so make them nice and long so you
can actually distinguish it say oh right
that's what you're talking about be
obvious and exaggerated just so you
don't miss reject the absolute value of
a equals now let me introduce some
function notation I wonder how many of
you remember this from last year okay
what this means is the absolute value of
a can be one of two things and I'll tell
you what they are the absolute value of
a is just a if a is positive or zero
actually doesn't matter where this
before it goes okay so for example the
absolute value of 5 is just 5
right it's a positive number it stays
positive alternatively if it's not
positive
okay for example the absolute value
negative one if I get a chance diffusion
it's just one you take away the negative
sign it's going disappeared another way
you could be better is like what's the
size of this number
don't worry about which way it's facing
I don't care if it's going that way
we're going that way just tell me how
big it is
okay now how do i express this in this
scheme if a is positive then the
absolute value just a but if it is
negative and this is actually negative
negative one so I have to slap an extra
negative sign on it to sort of cancel
them out so this is my formal definition
and I think this is kind of the most
fundamental one a bit of a mouthful but
it's the most reliable because you can
always use it when we go to functions it
becomes the most useful for sorting out
which waits for all right definition -
one of the ways that you can get rid of
and positive or negative the sign of a
number is first to square it right
because we know you square a negative
number and then you don't know whether
it was negatives like where you came
from maybe five five they both have the
same square but of course you actually
have changed the value so we're going to
get back you take the square root so the
square root of a square isn't actually a
it's the absolute value of a and I think
I look at this example before right so
here do you see what happens that square
e gets rid of information right if I
were to now cover this you don't know
whether I came from a five square or a
negative five spread underneath the
square root and what you end up with
must be positive regardless okay so this
is our second definition
here comes the last one the absolute
value of a and I think this is the most
useful one going forward is the distance
its what am I was saying it is the
distance from a to the origin
it's the distance but magnitude you
don't have far you've gone okay now at
the moment to find the distance of a
number from the origin like say five
right well the distance is five the
distance of negative five is also fine
the reason why this becomes more useful
is because later on you can learn
numbers aren't just one-dimensional
numbers can actually be two-dimensional
and they can inhabit a place and this
distance definition is really important
now I'm going to give you two sort of
secondary definitions that come off of
this one and this one from here we can
also take the absolute value of a
difference now wonder if you can think
about this Julia if I change what's
inside here from just a to a minus B
again it's equal to one of two things
depending on what a minus B ends up
being equal to right so if anybody's
been these two numbers you're
subtracting to a difference if that ends
up being a positive number if a minus B
is positive okay what would the absolute
value
just like the ball you don't change that
night with positive take the absolute
value it's still said but if anybody's
being happens to do negative for
instance you no need to write this but
if I said that the absolute value of two
minus five well you can just work this
out like you work out normal brackets
two minus five of course is negative
three and I know how to deal with this
like I did over here this is three in
other words it's no longer two minus
five it's actually five minus two do you
see that it's actually flipped around
it's the same as applying a negative
sign to everything just like I did over
here okay okay
okay now I said that was a secondary
definition if you're taking the absolute
value of difference based on this one
well there's another secondary
definition
it's okay
are you from here how do I think about
the distance the results from this after
I'm gonna I rubbed it off and I'm gonna
write to do this is a distance right
both these cases it's three right we
just calculate it so how would you
express this as a distance in relation
to it I'm going to start the sentence by
is the distance but how am I going to
finish
when you do the absolute value of heat
right like the absolute dive negative
[ __ ] you starting from the origin the
reason why is you're comparing there's
no IV you're comparing negative one with
zero that's the origin we never write
minus zero because it doesn't change the
value of a number but that's actually
what you're comparing from that's like
your point of reference here you've
changed your point of reference you're
not comparing from the origin anymore
you're comparing with two so it's no
longer the distance from a to the origin
it's the distance from A to B because of
course the difference from 5 to 2 is 3
and the distance from 2 to 5 is still 3
does that make sense
see how it works out how this definition
is just expansions